(soft music)
- Hey.
So uh, Bill’s retirement dinner next week,
Are you and Anna carpooling?
- Uh...
Are me and Anna gonna what?
- Are you and Anna gonna
carpool straight from work
to Bill’s retirement dinner?
- No...
But we actually broke up.
So...
- Oh...
Oh no!
- Probably not gonna carpool.
- Right.
Huh.
God, I am so sorry, man.
- It’s okay.
I downloaded Tinder last night.
I know you’re married.
Did you just ever go on
there to see how you’d do?
- No.
- Right.
Well anyway, I haven’t filled
out the profile yet, but
it’s there.
Waiting.
- Good!
Good for you, man.
Okay, you’re processing
and you’re moving on.
Good.
Alright.
- She was my everything.
- Yeah.
(office phone rings)
- You know, we should go out!
You know?
Boys night out.
You, me, Elliot.
Well not Elliot, but like you and me,
we go out, we get some drinks,
we paint the town.
Look out, ladies!
- Yeah!
Yeah, actually tonight though,
tonight is night market
and let me tell you
about night market, okay?
So we do it every week, but somehow
it manages to stay new.
What we do is my wife
and I, we cook dinner,
a bunch of our couple friends come over,
somebody brings a bottle of wine,
and inevitably a spontaneous
game of charades breaks out—
- Okay, well after that we go get drinks.
- We’re kind in bed early
on school nights, you know?
(chuckles) Boring married life.
- Yeah.
Pretty boring.
- So how’s Anna?
- I mean, devastated.
You know, we were soul mates.
- So I heard you and Kalyn broke up.
- Yeah, it had run its course.
- You doing alright, or...?
- Could you pass the cream?
- Oh yeah, here you go.
- Thank you.
- So that’s why I’m gonna
award the Nether’s account
to Kalyn!
- You’re giving the adult
toy account to Kalyn?
- Yeah, Kalyn is carefree, he’s playful,
who better to lead an
account specializing in toys
for adults?
- Do you know what
adult toys are, Natalie?
- Yeah, I mean, bikes for two,
gin rummy, billiards.
Anyway, Anna, I want you to
be second chair on this one.
- Great choice, Natalie.
I really think Elliot is gonna be
the perfect second chair on this one.
- I actually said Anna, not Elliot.
- I think we all know that Elliot
would be the perfect choice
for the Nether’s account.
- No, nobody thinks that.
- Great, I’m glad it’s settled.
Welcome aboard, Elliot.
(office phone ringing)
- Hey, I’m sorry I took
your place on Nether’s.
I don’t know why Kalyn thinks
I’m some sort of sex expert.
Probably my musk.
- Kalyn is just processing our breakup.
- You guys broke up?
- Yeah, last night.
- Well didn’t he just meet your parents?
- That was regrettable,
but we all make mistakes.
Big mistakes.
- But I can assure you
it won’t affect our work.
We’re both professionals.
- You know Anna calls sex “bedtime” ?
Do you know how confusing that is?
- We’re actually talking about
Bill’s retirement party right now.
- Right.
- I can’t even believe he’s retiring.
- Anna has this mole on,
like, the small of her back,
and I’ve been taking
pictures of it to make sure
it’s not changing shape;
who’s gonna monitor it now, you know?
Not me!
(groans) Not me.
- Kalyn, can we talk?
- Sure.
- I wonder what the mole looks like.
- Bill’s retirement
party, are you driving?
I need a ride.
- Do you want to get back together?
- No!
Hey, I just want to discuss
remaining professional
in the workplace.
- Did I mean anything to you?
- What?
Please just pull yourself together, okay?
This job is important to me.
- Cold as ice.
Must be nice to not care
about anything, huh?
- Oh, you guys want to carpool to Bill’s
retirement dinner next week?
- Yes!
Finally.
- I’m gonna miss Bill.
We used to have cat play-dates every week.
Next week we were gonna go to Legoland.
(soft music)
(orchestral music)